لذلك يجب أن أقول إنه من الصعب حقًا
فهم كيف حدث كل هذا ،
فهناك تقارب عميق جدًا أكثر
بكثير مما كان عليه في ظل إدارة أوباما ، كما
تعلم ، هناك أشخاص يعتقدون في الواقع
ربما يكون هذا أمرًا نقلته المملكة العربية السعودية
وقد يكون فكرة
جيدة للآخرين  الأسباب
الجيدة التي يناقضها البيان الملكي
وموقف المملكة العربية السعودية
الثابت منذ
إنشاء دولة إسرائيل في
عام 1948 ، نحن نؤيد بشدة ودائمًا ما
ندعم بقوة قيام دولة فلسطينية
مع عاصمة في القدس الشرقية ،
فكيف يمكن لأي شخص الوصول من هناك إلى
أعتقد أن المملكة العربية السعودية قد وافقت على
بيان الرئيس ترامب.
علمت أن
أمريكا قد تغيرت منذ أن كنت
سفيراً وسمعت هذا من العديد من
الأمريكيين أن أمريكا اليوم
ليست تلك التي تركتها كسفير في
200  7